Data analysis with Python Zero to Pandas
is a practical beginner friendly and coding
focused introduction to data analysis.
This is a live online course and
you can earn a verified certificate
of accomplishment by completing this course
if you are interested in learning data science
with python but don't know where to start
then this course is designed just for you you
can learn more and register at xero2pandas.com.
By the end of this course you will be able to
confidently use the python programming language
and its amazing ecosystem of data science
libraries like numpy for mathematical and
statistical computing pandas for data processing
and analysis matplotlib for creating beautiful
visualizations and much more you will get a
chance to practice and improve your skills
with weekly assignments and you will also work
on an end-to-end course project where you will
perform data analysis on a large real-world
dataset this is a beginner-friendly course
so you don't need to have any prior
knowledge of python or data science
some basic programming knowledge will
be helpful. But don't worry if you don't
know programming you can learn these
concepts with a little extra effort.